go
first to three
this is the first of three because this
winter's final it's gonna be whoever
gets the three matches oh man
damn arcades
sorry i had to phrase it like that but
you know you never know some people
might not know so we gotta talk about it
anyways we're gonna go into the match up
here
this is a race to three first of three
matches big daddy mike versus dvk this
is the match that we were just talking
about brian fury
brian fury from tekken 3 vs miguel from
tekken 6.
he's trying to taunt that upper or maybe
try taunt four two one four or something
no i want to give people the benefit of
the now they're doing tons of numbers
uh honestly i think right now my
favorite to win the tournament is dvk
but big daddy mike
turned things around against calum
earlier
here we go
oh
damn i love that hit
oh no off axes combo whips big daddy
mike ready for it gets the launch
expands the raid drive just to confirm
the kill
yep made it count
oh northern cross nice punish there not
safe
see what he does here oh
if he converted on that that would have
been sick
dbk with the with the with the vengeance
here looking to come back
see what he does
and miguel you know miguel i feel like
is one of those characters that doesn't
get enough respect you know we we rarely
see him in competitive play but he's
definitely a character that can that can
duke it with the best of them
yeah miguel definitely beats me up
though man since tekken 6.
[Music]
here we go pushing towards the wall here
one more he could do it goes for the
shoulder lean oh my gosh
i rarely see that move hit but it's
beautiful whenever i see it because he
goes woohoo
he's happy
most rifles just run up and do it you
know
yeah
that was sick
and it was oh
nice has the wall here do it oh he went
for it yeah yeah gotta respect
follow up here
let's see what he goes for still could
do with the pressure he went for the
interrupt
i thought he was gonna punish it yeah
running punch here the follow with the
lows do it again
oh my gosh i would have ducked the
fourth one down
oh god i've been rich again
check i love it
all right dvk staying alive in this
first game here
ready ducky but gets back kicked right
after man that was such a good option
nice gets to grab here see what it is he
has the wall positioning as well this
could be bad probably he might be dead
he might be dead boy yes
easy so easy keep it simple the perfect
for big daddy mike to close out game
number one as i said he's my favorite
right
yeah i mean that sequence at the very
end is very convincing because you got
to remember that taunt
it guarantees if the taunt hits it
guarantees the follow-up and there's a
number of moves that brian can do
but if you see that that taunt hit that
causes a move follow-up to be guaranteed
you know there's a
if you want to be amazing and do
something crazy you could do the jet
upper which is of course frame perfect
double double frame perfect because you
have to execute it fast enough but
there's a number of other moves you can
do to just even get the knock down but
it was great stuff there good good
presence of mind knowing that he would
tech roll and put him into that
unblockable position yeah in that
situation when they have one pixel left
and if you hit anything you're going to
win the game like you don't go for
anything more than that if you are
you're trying to style on them right
uh that dvk is a very strong competitor
so i would not try to give them any
chances like you get the thought you're
doing the most simple thing to get the
damage get it done close it out
yeah the good times anyways we'll see
um going back to the drawing board maybe
because this is an extended sense of
course players if they lose have the
option to switch characters right it's
either switch characters or they get to
pick the stage so i'm wondering here
what's going on in his mind what is he
going to do how is he going to kind of
change things up or is he just going to
stick to the same character
i don't know anything about dvk but i'm
going to assume he's a character
loyalist
you think so you think miguel players
are
yeah i think yoshi and yoshi players and
miguel players are i'll see
not gonna stick to miguel he's gonna
definitely switch to regular gin
he wasn't even a real miguel he's going
to gin
miguel's my third area bro here comes my
gin
all right
well let's see if jin kazama is able to
do it
if gin kazama can't do it maybe steve
kazama could do it i
i really thought that he was gonna stick
to miguel i really liked this miguel i
think that it was fine
uh yeah but let's see i wonder i wonder
what the logic is in picking ginger
maybe he wants to parry some of these
brian attacks
i honestly don't know but i mean jin is
a good character so we'll see you
we might have our first electric of the
day
huh let's see what happens
oh
gotta be careful so far the gin pick i
mean he needs to clutch it out it hasn't
paid off yet
that's an opportunity but again he does
have some flexibility with the lows
times the wasting he's gonna have to
react he'll sweep into the orbital wow
round two you gotta be careful you gotta
be careful
nice demon paw start things off here
big daddy mike again confident there
with that three plus four
controlling that open space here there's
an electric
sometimes you got to do it just keep
them honest
see what he does here again with the
demon paw
again he still needs to i feel like he
needs to kind of establish himself here
with the lows
there you go there's one way to do it
do it again oh he he has a splat oh that
was enough damage it's okay it's okay
i mean with that lively there it's
really hard to make a comeback from that
situation dbk on the scoreboard again
wow
demons has one plus two the follow-up
here
let's see what he does does he get the
wall he does oh he missed it standing to
the savage sword he got greedy
yo
that hit that would have been disaster
but luckily slightly mistimes the back
four
man i love the in and out movement from
dvk right now good life but the hatchets
are going to come
big daddy mike nose created making
comebacks has really oh
he should be dead caledonia should be
dead oh man that was crazy anyways good
stuff here for big daddy mike here
looking to extend his lead he wants to
go up 2-0 but dvk really needs this he
doesn't want to be in a situation where
he has to win three straight games
oh oh oh here we go
all right standing jab savage sword
keeps him at the wall the spring kick
able to get the momentum off of him
good punish
see what he does here
again looking for that opening looking
for an opportunity oh he tried a hot
kick
oh
yeah he wasn't he didn't have the wall
there
he could have changed things if he did
have it
and again ending with the taunt into a
follow-up and right now big daddy mike
is up 2-0 here in our winner's finals
one more match could seal the deal where
he'll earn himself a spot in our grand
finals
but right now i mean
you got to think about it what are you
going to do because you're in a
situation where you're down 2-0 you have
to switch
to a character and you're going to be
stuck with a character you have to win
three straight
three straight if you want to advance
i think he should have stuck to miguel
right for the whole set but the gin my
issue with this gin is like he plays a
kind of miguel like he doesn't play like
a mission
you know he doesn't he doesn't have the
whiff punch it's like an electric or
like a dash electric right yeah and i
feel like if you want to switch to a gin
especially when you're talking about the
winners final of a big tournament uh you
gotta have those electrics ready you
know you can't play gin uh the basic
non-mishima style which you know i feel
like a lot of players forget that you
can play a lot of these mishima
characters without that wave dash and
they can still be effective but once you
get at the top of the competition you
got to have all the pieces of the puzzle
right you have to have the wave dash you
got to have everything there and right
now that looks like it's lacking
yeah you got to be on point uh every
step of the way i mean
i think
learning for opportunities and making
sure that you take advantage of them is
super important if you guys are just
tuning in you guys are watching the
tekken online challenge for south africa
we're in the middle of our winners final
right now between uh big daddy mike and
dvk mozambique vs kenya is gonna stick
to gin
this is a decision because he has he has
to stick to jin the entire time
the entire time
here we go
maybe he's maybe he needs some warm-up
maybe he's feeling
himself round one i mean there were a
few situations here one of the
unfortunate ones too is when he went for
the parry into the punch series but then
of course he got blocked and he got jet
upward he and big daddy mike was ready
for it
yeah that's uh definitely one of those
things you gotta find and that's been
working out right forward forward to zen
oneplus 2. uh that like is like a weird
setup like you can just duck and launch
him and it's not really a good strong
midfault that he's gonna kill you with
but
big daddy mike has been copper that a
couple times already so dvk definitely
recognizing that and pulling the trigger
on capitalizing on it early yeah you
have to actively be blocking if you try
to do anything else even in neutral
you're going to get launched
oh he's trying to sidestep he could have
sidestepped
that's what he does here
not enough to kill gotta be careful yep
he does such a good job of hitting the
brakes right i feel like that's been one
of the differences that i've seen
between big daddy mike and his opponent
so far today uh ender round situation he
just seems to be more close than
everyone
[Music]
all right let's see what he does
oh
didn't duck in there you got to be able
to kind of get those openings and right
now dbk is not looking good big counter
hit for big daddy mike see what he does
oh damn he wanted it he is trying he's
trying to make me rip off my shades rip
off my headset and scream around my
house at six in the morning that's what
he wants for
that i mean i'll do it i'll do it he's
upstairs oh you're he's big chilling
dude nice hopkins let's get a noise
complaint
let's do it
let's get it
here we go kelsey oh no the get up kick
he's looking to close it out he should
be able to get it here
there it is big daddy mike one round
away from securing a spot in our grand
finals will he be able to do it or will
dvk be able to fight back
bbk's not looking too bad you know these
were close rounds so far in this third
match
it's always the end around situation
holy mod kick that was from around the
world that was crazy brian was facing
the wrong direction when i started i
feel like yo if he doesn't get the time
jet upright don't count to me
it don't count to me you better do it
oh he doesn't even need
yeah he definitely did it because man
that was clean
oh yeah very clean big daddy mike going
on
to the grand finals guaranteeing himself
a top to finish here congratulations big
daddy mike uh the brian fury looking
good so far man looking good dvk down
losing